Dell partner stein der
2013 in ägypten gefunden wurde ist ein ganz besonderer stein er ist kein gewöhnlicher
Asteroid sondern stammt zumindest in teilen nicht aus dem sonnensystem aber woher jetzt wurde er genauer
analysiert und offenbart ein sehr seltsames innenleben klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja schon bei den ersten analysen des steins wurde erstaunliches zu tage gefördert der hypatia stein besteht in seinem inneren aus
diamanten und es war sehr schnell auch klar dieser stein bzw
Bestandteile kommen aus dem interstellaren raum wir hatten ja letztlich hier über den ersten dokumentierten
vorbeiflug eines
interstellaren objekt berichtet dass so seltsam war das ein
außerirdisches raumschiff nicht
Ausgeschlossen wurde und das objekt auch darauf hin untersucht wurde der hypatia stein ist so seltsam dass
er wohl
aus bestandteilen die von außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
Stammen besteht wie seltsam sein innenleben ist das wurde jetzt von einem forschungsteam der university of johannesburg in südafrika
Untersucht und es ist tatsächlich verblüffend nicht in und an diesem stein gleicht einem stein hier von der erde oder aus unserem sonnensystem
dabei sind die enthaltenen
diamanten noch ziemlich gewöhnlich sie sind wahrscheinlich
durch den hohen druck beim aufprall auf die erde entstanden und sie haben dazu geführt dass der stein
So gut erhalten ist aber was sonst noch
So in dem stein enthalten ist das ist nichts mit nichts hier aus dem sonnensystem
vergleichbar die zusammensetzung ist ganz anders zitat aus der untersuchung die mineral matrix
Des steins unterscheidet sich deutlich von allem was wir bislang in anderen meteoriten gefunden haben selbst wenn wir die gesamte erde zu staub
zerkleinern könnten so erhielten wir eine durchschnittlich gleiche chemische
zusammensetzung dieses staubs wie wir sie auch in sogenannten schon tritt meteoriten finden in konkreten erwarten wir einen kleineren anteil
kohlenstoffs und einen größeren anteil
siliziums aber in der matrix die partnerstadt finden wir einen großteil an kohlenstoff und einen
ungewöhnlich kleinen anteil von silizium, zudem enthält der stein ein anteil polycyclische aromatische
Polizisten den interstellaren staub befinden die mitglied georgi berlin untersuchte das innenleben des stands genauer und schießt auf etwas wirklich verblüffendes
Reines aluminium das gibt es auf der erde gar nicht und kommt wahrscheinlich so auch nirgendwo
Im sonnensystem vor und weitere substanzen enthält der stein mit denen so niemand gerechnet hat die gesamte
zusammensetzung
Des steins lässt für das forschungsteam jetzt nur einen schluss zu der stein kommt nicht nur aus dem interstellaren raum ebenfalls bestimmte anteile und diese
Bestandteile die sind auch älter als unser sonnensystem und er ist bei sehr niedrigen temperaturen
entstanden wahrscheinlich so bei minus 196 grad celsius ja und seine sehr
exotische zusammensetzung die wirft jetzt einige fragen auf wie ist unser sonnensystem genau entstanden also aus welchen gasen wie sieht's bei anderen sternen systemen aus
Wenn die
zusammensetzung so anders ist
Dann ist vollkommen unklar wo er entstanden ist ja eher wird der wissenschaft wohl noch einige zeit rätsel aufgeben und ob seine herkommt überhaupt geklärt
Werden kann das ist mehr als ungewiss wenn er über die neuesten erkenntnisse dazu
Informiert werden wollt dann drückt nun aber aufs auge und vergessen ich den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken interstellare objekte moore
rätsel gelöst ja ansonsten
Bis dann bleibt dran